i saw a study last week that
had researchers asking participants to
rate emotional and physical pain of a
breakup they found that women tend to be
more negatively affected by breakups
reporting high levels of both physical
and emotional pain but while breakups
hit women the hardest they tended to
recover more fully men on the other hand
rarely fully recovered i thought that
was very interesting i wasn't too sure
what that meant yeah it's interesting um
it also rings true with my my experience
and my observations it i i think i mean
this could relate to a number of things
and here i'm painting with a broad brush
right but um you know how comfortable
one is
feeling their feelings is male or female
is going to strongly dictate how quickly
one moves through grief this is the same
thing as trauma the more willing someone
is to feel the full depth and intensity
of the feelings that they associate with
that trauma the more quickly they're
going to move through
the trauma again i'm lifting from paul
conte's word so these aren't mine but
you know people use a number of
strategies they use distraction
they use states like they sublimate to
things like anger
um and avoidance of various kinds in
order to not feel the traumatic feelings
or not feel the breakup people will you
know try and self-suit with alcohol or
try and sell soothe with multiple new
partners or whatever it happens to be it
doesn't work
just extends it because this map of
space-time and closeness needs to be
fractured and the only way to do that is
for the brain to have to confront the
reality which is that
whether by death or by by breakup they
are no longer available it's like the
food on the other side of that wall
is gone it's just not there anymore
uh or that the food that was accessible
now there's a wall in between and you
will not get through it and you know you
can see this actually in animal studies
that are kind of hard they're actually
very hard to watch you'll see the animal
perseverate literally damage his own
body trying to get through a barrier to
something it's highly motivated to see
people do that post breakup they usually
do that by talking to everybody about
the breakup
which is its own form of perseverating
on the motivation what did i do what did
i do wrong this and that and some of
that analysis is healthy some of it's
not now why
would one group
be
more let's just say effective at dealing
with breakups it's probably the ability
to really feel the full intensity of how
sad it is and be able to confront that
and here i'm you know i'm a male i've
only ever lived in a male body so all i
can tell you is that i think from a very
early age um there's a an ability that
at least
i'm sure it transcends to women too um
or extends to women too but learning to
pack down feelings right and so when are
we really talking about when we're
talking about pack down feelings i'm not
a psychologist but what we learn is top
down control for brain to autonomic
control it's the same thing like i don't
want to jump off the high dive or i
don't want to do this public speaking
but i'm going to i'm going to kind of
like i'm just going to force myself i'm
going to david goggins it right
grief is is an autonomic state
we say it has valence has negative
valence but it's high levels of
autonomic arousal with a negative
connotation because you can be high
levels of autonomic arousal with
happiness right you can be very alert
and aroused and happy very alert and
aroused and sad it's very alert and
aroused and sad
and yet
we learn how to tamp that down
what is tamping down it's reducing our
heart rate it's
going to work each day being a
functional human being you know there's
a lot of that
rather than
allowing ourselves to you know sob
uncontrollably into a pillow
some people are better at this i mean
the late steve jobs was a big proponent
of scream therapies he used to go up
into the hills behind stanford he
actually owned still owns the property
back there he was really into
you know catharsis cathartic release of
internal state that he felt would allow
him to like return a happier nicer
person he was also kind of well known
for screaming at people in the office so
he obviously had a lot pent up inside um
so i think
the better that we can lean into
the emotional states that we fear the
most but in a controlled
way where we're not harming ourselves or
other people the better the more that we
try and avoid that and we try and
sublimate or just you know i've done
this so i'm speaking from experience you
know i would use the anger or the
sadness from an experience to just work
ten ten times longer ten times harder to
just get that much more focus you're
taking that autonomic arousal that
narrow aperture and that energy and
you're putting it onto something that
moves your life forward so in some cases
that's good because you still need to
function and give but it can give you
the
here i'll just say it it gave me the
illusion that i was working through
something because you get all the
accoutrements and rewards of hard work
but what you don't do is remap that
space-time closeness map and then you
find i guarantee
you find yourself five or ten years
later wondering why you're so exhausted
or why certain things in life aren't
going well and it's because when they
say you haven't dealt with the loss you
never actually allowed yourself to feel
the feelings but once you do
it's like a valve it releases you hear
musicians say that the most recent album
was [ __ ] because i didn't have any
heartbreak to work through right and it
is strange how people
it's a difficult thing to pass because a
little bit of it is kind of like alchemy
right a little bit of it is kind of like
turning something that's terrible into
something that's useful and beautiful
it's fuel
but
you're right it is a it's a
hiding away
from what it is that you actually need
to do from the work that you need to do
and in a world which is a meritocracy
where people want success and status and
accolade and fame and you go well
enemies and
revenge and bitterness resentment
pretty good motivators maybe i could use
some of that maybe i should go out of my
way to try and put myself into positions
where this motivates me and working out
where that falls on the ledger is is a
difficult one it is and i think it
depends on life stage and it depends on
how one is going to work it out i mean
the the narrative around the shark dive
i mean even as i say it now several that
was 2017 was the second dive when i
think about all that i think that was
crazy i was out there studying fear and
i almost was the professor who died
studying fears it would have been a
terrible end to the story um what was i
doing don't do this don't do this but
you know there are times in our life
where we feel compelled to take on
certain challenges for whatever reason
there's a phrase that doesn't exist in
the scientific literature but it
captures two um components of physiology
that are absolutely factual earlier we
talked about limbic friction
as it relates to creative process and
sublimation of anger and sadness and
creating things from bad
events books music etc
the words that come to mind are limbic
resonance the
human beings
resonate
with these extreme states you know there
aren't many great albums written about
a good day walking on a sunday in the
park like it's kind of boring i mean
there's the beautiful painting sunday in
the park with george but i'll be honest
it's beautiful but it's also kind of
boring you can look at the details of it
for a while people like intensity the
scream is you know people can look at
that for a long time and it speaks to
the psychosis of the artist etc
you know people don't generally bond
through passive relaxed states unless
they've also been through a lot together
right i mean even think about uh the we
could talk about this separately if you
want but all of us are here because of
the autonomic seesawing that is the
reproductive act it goes from highly
aroused how you refer to it in your lab
yeah scientists autonomic see-saw it is
it's very interesting that the arousal
process is one of increase in autonomic
arousal
in order to get true arousal but then
not so much that it inhibits arousal
then mating behavior and then the the
orgasm response in males and females is
highly what we call sympathetic not
emotionally some it can be i suppose
emotionally sympathetic but from a pure
physiology standpoint it's a activation
hyperactivation of the stress system
even though it has positive valence and
then
there's a very quick rebound to the
so-called parasympathetic arm of the
autonomic nervous system this deep
relaxation which we don't really know
why i wasn't consulted the design phase
but we think that that postcoital bliss
and is and the kind of relaxing the
desire to not run around a bunch more
for most people was to exchange odorant
molecules to increase pair bonding and
even if people aren't trying to pair
bond because people don't always just
mate to reproduce
but
that uh some of the molecules that are
released in each of the two individuals
oxytocin being the main one
give people a sense of kind of
post-coital bliss and and it's a very
calm one that creates opportunity for
bonding and discussion is all called
like pillow talk there are other forms
of pill
not clarity and true but for women it
might be something different right of
course a different different name i only
speak in the language of physiology but
for both men and women this happens it
creates this little orb of closeness
that is both physiological and but
neurochemical too so what we can say for
sure is that whether or not it was in
vivo or in a dish we are all here
because two parents
right a male and a female unless you're
a condor where two females can produce a
baby this has now been shown right but
as far as we know where a male and a
female reproduce because they each went
through this arc of arousal
not too high arousal extreme stress
relaxation that happened separately or
together because in vitro it could be
fertilization could be separate so the
test of whether or not we get to
reproduce
is actually the ability to to
assuming that people are doing this
together and not through uh in vitro
fertilization is a test of whether or
not people can coordinate their
autonomic nervous systems now there are
ways around that and to override it but
by and large
that's the way humans evolved in the way
all other animals evolved what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
you